troisième titre à la une de l'actualité
de terrorisme la police espagnole a
arrêté à barcelone et valence six
militants d'extrême droite qui serait
compromis dans les attentats meurtriers
de la gare de bologne soulevez-vous en
1979 en italie et dans le massacre de la
rue copernic à paris en 1980 avant
d'aller plus loin
le rappel de ces deux attentats dont on
n'a jamais réellement retrouver les
auteurs mêmes leurs traces tour de
crespin 3 oct à 80 18h30 devant la
synagogue de la rue copernic 10 kg de
plastique explose il était placé dans
les sacoches d'une moto avant de nous
devant l'édifice
bilan quatre morts neuf blessés
l'analyste l'analyse et des restes de la
bombe démontre l'origine étrangère de
l'engin peut-être checke jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
l' enquête n'a permis de découvrir ni
les auteurs ni les raisons dans un
premier temps la police suspecte la fan
groupe français d'extrême droite
elle abandonne très vite cette hypothèse
et retient depuis ce bâtiment un
groupuscule d'extrême droite ont
espagnole et la piste palestinienne
encore appelée moyen-orient une faction
qui seraient manipulés par le front du
refus
deux mois plus tôt 2 août 80 j'ouvre des
départs en vacances
la foule est dense sur les quais de la
gare de bologne 10h25
c'est l'explosion dix kilos de tnt dans
une valise en une seconde la moitié du
bâtiment essoufflé bilan 76 morts 200
blessés
très vite le régime criminel ne fait
plus de nouvelles
l'opération aurait été revendiqué par
des terroristes du groupe extrême droite
les noyaux armées révolutionnaires l'on
parle aussi les brigades rouges
un jeune italien mi-temps extrême droite
est arrêtée et internée à nice
france